you
this is the cube fanatics just starting
any second right now so I need to put on
my running shoes here okay here we go
double those points and let's get
rolling give me this thing I have very
little time these games are becoming
more and more difficult
the higher the rating the more difficult
life is less time let's try this and
then Queen h4 stuff maybe maybe I'm not
gonna Castle let's do this maybe I
should have done that first this is
actually a good move a bad move on my
part let's run away voluntarily I want
my knight here yeah I think g6 then I'm
kicked off of this file h4 gets in the
way of my queen dropping back to h4
let's do this though right here
not so fast all right let's jump in here
Oh Forks no Knights e5 this is gonna
turn to be pretty good I think
okay good thing can I get rid of that
bish up the pressure on this pot drop my
queen back to f3 I'm not sure what
exactly that's doing but I really do
like my Knights my bishop just now going
to reroute to c4 and I want to get on
this diagonal okay I have a bunch of
exchanges let's go here I guess I guess
let me castle now well this square right
I want to get a queen battery I'm on
this pond Bishop d3 can I get a mate
soon Kings running for his life
it's definitely running for his life I
have this I have this let's just do that
we're dancing we're clearly just dancing
and now I'm on the rook on this
everything should be falling very soon
back to tournament Oh
oh man okay
superfish superfish going for an f7
trick okay isn't this an overextended
pond let's break this down here is there
gonna be Queen checks is there going to
be Queen checks I jump in here I got to
take a mic no I didn't have to
necessarily do that but let's do this
there's gonna be a sacrifice there it is
my Queens gonna have to be careful I
have to be very careful whoa okay I
don't have to worry about that I just
run away actually
I'm dropping that pun which it could
have been taken that was a very
roundabout way to capture at the end of
it you didn't get captured okay let's
move out of the way
hit the night and hit this night at both
nights he's gotta go somewhere that he
doesn't like let's oh my goodness I
nearly fell from h7 oh that's scary
that's very scary isn't it let's do this
and give up some material I'm okay with
that
I like my knight on d4 he's a machine
isn't he look at these Knights they're
monsters let's kick this Queen away and
get my bishop to a useful square
he loves f6 my bishop is falling in love
with f6 I'm gonna take this and support
it challenged b3 he's defended still
this a a3 b3 he's passed now this pounds
gonna fall though he's gone just like
that but he's supported he's passed I
thought for a second I thought for a
second I was the one who's down on time
but that's not the case there's
potential mate on g2 that is me back to
tournament
12-12-12 it's actually those two games
it was my opponent who was down on time
usually can I get a quick me I gotta go
for some tricky stuff every now and then
it's okay to go for some tricky stuff
you have to win and win fast when he
went fast is the plan
and at the same time you know what
you're doing you keeping your opponent
honest you're saying you think you could
just pre move all you want I'm gonna
make you think twice about pre moving
watch out for that f7 strike I want to
get some expansion with B 584 stuff
alright maybe I have to do it in this
manner King side castle alright it's a
very slow game can we open it up here
actually I should have done this move
sooner cuz you know what it's doing it
were what it would have been doing
forking my opponent with d5 this Knight
was on that square this bishop is
actually dead though which is a good
thing that's nice I'm gonna drop my
knight back here so there's no Knight g5
stuff looking for made on each - that
could be very cramping take at the pond
I'm just looking to trade Queens can you
believe that I could take this pawn with
check but I'm he's insignificant I'm I
want to really address this black Queens
position so I don't know that it really
matters in which way I take actually and
Queen here was better to make sure I
have the trade happening I was focused
on f3 I had g4 available my Knights they
recaptured there's some Forks here less
than 10 seconds for my opponent I just
take care to open up the F file or will
I
let's do this first I shouldn't have
captured I have to worry about rook g8
stuff let's just do that
there's no ton back to tournament twenty
six twenty six twenty twenty twenty
twelve oh man all right let's see what
is with these five moves okay okay I
have to work around it I'm gonna have to
work around that
what's that Knight up to somebody tell
me okay this is this is netting a pawn
cannot be taken it could take here as an
intermediate move
I have bishop blocks here I'm biting on
a rock with d5 but maybe I could
eventually undermine that he's not this
Bishop isn't going anywhere so I'm not
gonna take him right away
he's still not going anywhere and maybe
I could do something with this take here
I'm looking for some tricky stuff with
the knight g3 I want to control this
diagonal first reroute my bishop like so
actually I'm not gonna have that more
available am i that night g3 stuff with
H for some lever I'm two bishops versus
the two knights can I open this position
up is the big question get my rooks
working laterally I have pressure on
this pawn f4 kick this Knight around and
why I'm gonna open up this diagonal so I
want to get on these two diagonals right
now so open this up this Knight is
kinetic find himself in a pin 90 for
ease it's a pin and a win so there's
check let's get my dark square Bishop
working which is gonna take a little bit
of an effort here oh hang on dark square
bishop actually it's gonna be blockaded
or maybe not 20 seconds to 24 that's a
free night okay I still want to get on
this diagonal stay here night here okay
I just back up oh I'm on the rook
who's on that rook just take three
pieces take three pieces that was the
freest rook around let's give some
checks let's take a pawn here quickly
it's been a while since I played any um
any bullet games I've been playing these
are five-minute ones why did I take that
pun I was gonna get a trying to get
another Queen there's no time though no
time to get that Queenie thirty eight
thirty eight thirty thirty twenty four
okay alright whoa oh my goodness that ah
it's gonna kill me one of these days
it's gonna kill me the adobe flash
gambit
I've yet to disable that button before
any of these live streams okay
trade this light square bishop actually
let's get rid of him he's a bad man
he's a bad man all right let's stick my
up let's go here I was gonna throw him
on d6 let's trade everything let's just
trade everything you're gonna get play
for the rooks play here I'm looking to
take the pawn or trade Queens let's
trade Queens there we go you know double
up on this pond he's actually lost and
there'd be a check thrown in first get
out of that Bishop move I have that I
sure what that Lou's doing there's a
better way to convert this okay now I
have an idea let's pile up on f7 pigs
are loose
the pigs are loose here okay I really
want to just pin that [ __ ] up
my opponents not letting me do that so
my king is now gonna sneak over to g5
and okay they reside back to terminate
fifty to fifty two forty two thirty all
right
c5 okay we're having some typos I think
I did miss play yeah I missed the move I
should have had a knight in sooner cuz
now I gotta go in reverse I talked about
that in that game Aronian versus Aronian
Gelfand
I didn't follow my own advice here okay
let's get rid of him and let's let's
jump around here train a little bit I
could definitely take I actually my
knight is so stupid he's got to go to
the corner it's okay to take that pawn
actually it really would have been okay
how you know you're having a tough day
when you have to improve your Knights
position by throwing him in the
let's reposition my night and from the
corner yeah I really don't even know
what I'm doing my night I just now I do
he's hitting everything the whole family
is gone
just like that we are going to trade now
over and over and over and more trades
here happening I probably could have
taken that 20 seconds to 26
could we just trade here I really want
to just trade okay closer to trading
they're ready to attack my rook here oh
oh I have a plan I think oh they just
gave that up okay so it's easier to pre
move and twelve seconds
oh no no no no no no no no no okay March
pon run you are very fast in your past
fast and past all right watch out for
stalemates Oh could I just make up my
mind okay I have a plan a very clear
plan stepladder no no no I think that
might have been close to stalemate or
maybe not yeah I was at square back to
term in 72 50 40 to 18 minutes remaining
was this economy I recently played
that's how fast these games are going
you don't even realize how or who you're
playing how you're playing or what your
play how you're playing how am I playing
or who you're playing all right let's
get developed here Knight f5 all right I
can't support them I could do this that
I want my knight on c5 or jump in here
all right maybe I don't want that and c5
Knight here is gonna be annoying isn't
it I have a majority over here my queen
is having to babysit this Knight not fun
not fun all right
the rook could be taken but not yet the
queen was said
push is available pawn push is not
available I can't do this I should have
done Bishop to e5 exchange dark square
bishops and look to exploit f6 and h6
now I'm gonna get steamrolled I'm
getting pushed around tsunami of puns
there isn't a bishop block support my
night so I could push this pawn finally
I actually let me just give him up that
was a free night wasn't it I'm gonna
take care let's keep pushing these guys
are passed let's jump in here 20 is
about even on the clock pawn push next I
should've been doing this yesterday
should have been pushing these pawns
yesterday okay jump in here and then
pawn push right there these rooks aren't
doing anything they're not even they're
not on open files of a new queen might
resigned I have I had that rook I'm
still in the rook that would have been
bad what's my bishop doing nothing 15
seconds
let's take care jump mine the Queen in
there I can't even name pieces it's
ready to come my queen a knight
okay they don't have any time they don't
have any time back to tournament 90 oh
my goodness 90 56 56 56 okay 16 minutes
remaining
this term is flying by it really is
Smith more gambit declined Oh dark
Square weaknesses I think f4 was men I
don't think that this is a good plan cuz
now I get this break in successfully or
if my opponent gives up that dark square
Bishop there's gonna be big trouble
big trouble on the dark squares being
highlighted right now and I really don't
want a castle I think I'll go Queen side
maybe I go capture that pawn now
probably get trapped with that for
something straight here they would never
take this pawn
they'll take this one though okay okay
Queen trade happening soon
oh that was almost a really bad mouse
limb we're about even on the clock it
should still be a struggle for my
opponent to do something I think I'm
gonna keep my rook around not so quick
to trade in this position in other
positions yes pawn push next and then
undermine this structure kick this night
away let's do this
get my bishops on adjacent diagonals
it's tough to get out of that pin
I want my rook on G something g5 maybe
that pawns hit 20 it's too close to call
too close to call here my king is gonna
go on f6 let me just get rid of that
Knight way way too tricky here I just
repaired their pawn structure
I want my [ __ ] up on d7 and then my
rook could be freed up King here
I could take this pawn it's pinned okay
I'm getting some material I'm defending
this pawn he wants to get marching now
keep marching now my rook is freed up I
want my rip doing something else
that's not good here let's get my pawns
working rook here and then to g2 less
than 7 seconds oh that's me that's very
good and you realize that I should have
realized that 110 88 72 okay where are
those quick wins Oh last last tournament
I did I was talking about trying to get
mate on h7 to try to get maid on h2 or
age 7 I think that's too many pawn
advances so now I could grab material
I'm not going to I could have taken with
the bishop in there I don't want to give
up my LightScribe bishop he's gonna fall
now I think you just Castle maybe I
should have done this move let's get out
of this I'm playing f4 upon really gonna
move yes he is I'm gonna take that night
and then jump here an in-betweener know
they have an in-betweener they could
have taken my bishop whit's check we
both missed it Oh forks
watch out for those Forks Queen here's
available
I have a cop I would have a
counter-attacking move though with um
with Bishop d2 and now they're light
squares are weekend so let's go
somewhere at my queen they're flying
Bishop takes pawn the queen is dead the
queen is dead she's not moving it's
matin too soon with some f5 move
involved right are they gonna move I
could do this no matter what even if
they take my rook it doesn't matter
I have this stop happening okay that's
me take the rook or or go they're back
determine 150 150 90 90 okay I need a
quick strike and it's not happening
against this guy I know he knows all
about it so let's get some expansion on
the Queen side and let me get take that
it's a free pun yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
come back here keep your night out of
play
all right let's look I got established
upon in the center I end up getting this
it's gonna be tricky
my bishops there to defend I guess I'm
gonna try for f5 Maya Knight is defended
and now he could jump in here or here my
mother
Brooke just want a piece another piece
my opponent is flying at me I'm taking
everything right the kitchen sink the
kitchen sink just don't get mated I'm
looking for matin - its check they just
discovered check I'll take with the
night and then move with the night you
know resign Knight move and it's very
close to mate night here pawn block
stuff or just queen h2 Queen H - H - I
should focus that h2 150 110 110 can I
catch that guy can I catch that guy 11
minutes to try and catch 150 I need some
sneaky sneaky tricks me one to h4 pawn
push Bishop h6 all right they're kicking
my bishop around Bishop h6 let's go
trade that dark square bishop
let's keep the knight out of f5 let's
jump in here take the bishop mate next
I'm also on f7 they take I got me that's
made on h7 back to tournament 130 room
151 3127 110 all right
c5 it's very aggressive
well it's getting some tempos here I'm
gonna take okay this is just going to be
one now on f5 I'd have thought about I
could have thought about maybe a queen
check to induce some lights where
weaknesses g3 in particular oh oh I was
hit with the bishop and that square so
take okay I've doubled pawns but but I'm
up upon and I'm pointing at age seven
now and let's get all my pieces working
all my piece is working and what next
Oh h2 and the road hmm that backfired
that defended against both very nice oh
I thought I was dropping my knight not
the case but he's too too close much too
close is that night okay King up King up
rook over I thought about clean here
that would not be good okay 22 seconds
and this is this is um how much material
I only have a pun oh I should've taken
one that's a pretty move mode alright
let's kick this night out of here he's
close to trapdoor you have to go in the
corner let's let's do that then I don't
want to trade rooks I want to I want to
do this and I'll take like this get my
King working 14 seconds get my king up I
want to target d4 next and he's falling
his pawn is falling the rook is stuck
it's interesting my rook active over
here they're probably play kingi - no
the rook has movement now but there
check and they're forced now to the back
rank and they're close to being in mate
type of position oh I'm dropping upon
let's go here instead be sneaky
let's give check time situation this
game is not ending anytime soon
no time soon so checks back to turn it
down on time 150 oh that guy he must be
having a really long game right now
150 150 we're tied and I'm apparently up
on tiebreaks
I guess they had to go by opponents
rating or something forget what that tie
break is we both have 12 games and let's
get all my pawns working it actually
maybe get an f5 push ok so my opponent
could get pushed around
f5 I really want to focus on dropping
that pond but ok we have to live with it
I want my knight on that 5 my rook was
really just recapturing so I could be
pivoting about on this score with pieces
and let's keep this Knight out of this
square my LightSquared Bishop needs to
get working my rooks gonna get kicked
let's drop back here I could do this
move Knights gonna jump in here I don't
want to do this because I give the g5
square up let's stop b5 although I don't
even know if I'm really stopping it
we're gonna see about that I'm hitting
the Queen there's maybe some issues on
these dark squares pawn push I could
defend how I'm gonna pin I need to get
out of that pin I've got to take with my
king to defend my bishop so I'm out of
that pin this pond is gonna follow
though gone just like that I'm on this
c4 pawn though let's get rid of him and
then run with my beep on no it's not my
V pun 21 seconds run you can't be cocked
can you you can't be caught that bishops
not fast enough he had a zigzag and he's
he's not he's not fast enough
he turned out to not be fast enough for
now this bishop his gun so my night is
going to no sneak around or actually let
me just get my other pieces working
that's tricky night she keeps giving
check he keeps giving check need to put
an end to that night he's not he has to
stop what he's doing right here you know
how that no stalemates
that's me back to tournament 170 188 171
76 minutes remaining
come on he's got 15 games in bulgar cap
negative 10 okay
Smith Maura oh I didn't want to accept
it I take back the accepted version
could it still happen in the accepted
version we're gonna see we're gonna see
age 200 oh that was there but one move
sooner oh I should have played here
sooner Queenie to the King can't escape
and stuff okay I could take this I think
safely pin them on each to again mating
to threat I mean to threat all the
bishops there to block Bishop has to
block I'm gonna attack the pin piece
attack the pin piece main threat again
Knight check here they resigned back to
tournament it's exactly what I needed
190 190 it's even 190 190 188 168 162
five minutes remaining
five minutes remaining you four I do
some gambit with you for sure I can is
this guy gonna play yes okay they're
going with some soft setup here like a
small pond center that you'd see in
Sicilian but I could eventually
establish a pawn on e5 I like my
LightSquared Bishop I was really gonna
play a three on my next move so this
night is kind of stranded maybe I want
to do this move right now yes let's do
it now before c5 is played too freely
and actually I'm just running that
material and I'm gonna take with my
knight maybe there's Bishop h5 stuff now
let's set it up Queen h4 stuff and then
it's
if I Sanji six so I'm gonna take here
with the bishop
if pawn push if King moves its check
actually he can run around in this
direction I'm gonna take the rook though
okay I wasn't checked their Knight
okay the knight spin the Knights lost
pawn put King f8 pawn push Bishop check
and then Queen takes here maybe
eventually a check where's the mate I
really just want of me I should have
given a check with the bishop first this
is not the most efficient way to do it
I miss my opportunity for mating very
quickly and getting a quick a quicker
when it's not available now let's get my
other rook working could probably go
here no matter what could take the
bishop as well oh except for that move
[ __ ] missed that move Oh
the Queen's dead though I have eat no I
don't have eight seconds my opponent has
that many seconds okay that's mate now
I'm pretty sure finally Oh 210 210 208
188 three minutes three minutes this is
like the third time I'm playing this guy
okay oh man alright can I control that
Square D for yes I can in fact Mike King
Knight is going to be focused on that
square I have this supported it still
can't be played I have too much defense
there knight is pinned I'll look to do
this move no he's still kind of pinned
my knight is unprotected and oh that's a
free piece they might resign are they
gonna resign right here and the rook is
close to trapped my bishop is kind of
too uncomfortable doing that I didn't
want to go over here my knight has a
home oh this here is better though my
Center is breaking down I want to
maintain this point as ugly as it looks
having these double isolated pawns this
pawn is doing a good job boxing out the
knight and now the knight is pinned oh
oh my goodness that almost happened
again
almost happened again close to me
actually close to me Queen takes here's
a mate threat that is me it's exactly
what I needed
2:38 2:30 2:30 3:00 left 2:30 2:30 2:30
oh okay this guy is not going to go into
the night quietly I just know it
oh hang on hang on a second okay how did
I Castle that's a question that I have
how does my opponent Castle I have this
and I have that as a threat are they
going to resign
they really resign this position after a
fork no no just like I said they're not
going into the night quietly I did this
so Knight g4 I could Castle artificially
let's pin this let's play here and take
like that and then push their night away
or maybe just take their night let's get
out of tricky tax discovered tricks
maybe I should just take and I should
just take an OK winning material now I'm
on h7 we're just gonna take here and
then take care mate threats in a couple
evasion on the light squares oh this is
mate if King goes here looking us to go
here okay where's that mate coming over
here they resigned back determine 250
250 one minute nineteen he's probably
ready to win though two fifty two fifty
two thirty eight I could end up first
second or third one minute I have to win
this game if this guy just clocked burns
there's no way I could win maybe he'll
resign in the objectively lost position
though what do you really do that
hopefully or maybe h2 could strike again
I'm setting it up you know you got a
castle right oh oh oh please just take
it
remove the knight move the knight h2 he
stood back tobe to 7258
oh he could still win he could still win
he's ready to win another game okay 40
how many how much time 37 seconds this
guy is gonna go after my queen
eventually there's this variation ie to
the stuff I got
try for a quick win are they comment are
they comment I saw the cube it's coming
are they calling it what is it what is
it what is it first
age - I'm telling you you have to watch
out for that H 2 square whoa a
buzzer-beater sort of good games all Wow
- 7258 - 5208 202 200 Wow
really really close Kyle here for Wow
fourth place land but there was a tight
pack all of us up in the 200s there very
nice alrighty tournament is crazy as
usual
you